critics and fans alike love the final
installment of the Guardians of the
Galaxy trilogy but one iconic accessory
was conspicuously absent from the
Blockbuster and now director James Gunn
has weighed in on making that call
Star-Lord and his space buddies
surpassed expectations for Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 earning huge box office
numbers as the Marvel Cinematic Universe
underdogs this final guardian's entry
gives a poignant farewell to its titular
Misfits and many viewers praised James
Gunn for his perfect swan song however
some fans wondered about its finer
details one common question on Twitter
after the film's release was what
happened to star-lord's helmet which he
never wears in the three cool well
that's a good question we know he gets a
new one between Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 2 and Avengers Infinity War but its
status in his latest Adventure puzzled
many fans fortunately we have an answer
for why Quill's essential headwear and
his clip-on rocket boots were missing
Gunn recently explained that because of
the urgency of his mission to rescue his
best friend Rocket Raccoon he left his
iconic Guardians gear behind on Twitter
where he often shares insights directly
with fans guns set the record straight
about quill not wearing a helmet in
volume 3 in a tongue-in-cheek reply in
response to one user's question he joked
it's in his desk drawer on nowhere he
had to get out of there fast as you know
while this lack of helmet can be easily
forgiven his enhanced Footwear
accessories very well could have made
for Handy tools on his quest as it turns
out Gunn cleared up this particular
matter as well in a less jokey manner
revealing that the guardian's technology
has advanced by Leaps and Bounds all
thanks to rocket gun posted the rockets
that clip onto his boots are far
inferior to the jet packs rocket has
made them so they're not around at all
anymore time and a super smart raccoon
then are the simple answers to this
apparent change to star-lord's character
even so there may still be a chance that
we'll see quill back in his old gear
down the line given that the ending of
volume 3 confirms Chris Pratt's MCU
future otherwise a lonely helmet
somewhere on nowhere May no longer have
an owner while Gunn may have jokingly
explained away star-lord's in-universe
mentality behind traveling without his
helmet some fans in a Reddit Thread
about this subject have proposed
additional theories about the decision
Gunn of course could have easily
Justified keeping the iconic headwear in
volume 3 but chose instead to alter the
character in a way plenty of fans found
noticeable in the thread's top comment
for example one user argued that
star-lord's lack of gear emphasizes his
singular focus on saving rocket
meanwhile another fan proposed that the
film May simply be trying to maximize
Chris Pratt's on-screen FaceTime in the
same manner Steve Rogers inexplicably
fights without a helmet during big
moments in the Avengers films prior to
Chris Evans Marvel Cinematic Universe
exit another user wrote I like this
interpretation some people had where
Peter wanted to distance himself from
Star-Lord ties in nicely with how he
went back to Earth At the end to his
roots as a human being and with his
grandpa since he leaves the Guardians
team at the end of the film it's
entirely possible then that Peter Quill
will remain unmasked in his future
appearances a new direction for his
character as he remains a big part of
the post Guardians MCU